I know so many people who say "I work in finance,...
...but I really, kind of, want to make sculptures",...
...or "I am a doctor, but my passion has been playing guitar on the weekends."
And I know so many people who are so talented,...
...who gave up to live a more conventional life...
...because of the fear and the doubts of what was possible.
Too many people let their fears and their doubt of what's possible derail them.
They were looking for jobs, they were looking to be hired.
I'm not looking for jobs, I'm not looking to be hired.
There is no freedom in security, but there's security in freedom.
Someone told me that many many years ago.
So for me, I chased freedom and I have security because I feel free.